Janet Reno the first female US Attorney  General has died at 78 years old from  complications of Parkinson's disease CBS  News confirms Reno passed away  peacefully at home early Monday morning  surrounded by family and friends Reno  was tapped by President Bill Clinton to  become the government's top lawyer in  1993 she remained Attorney General for  the remainder of Clinton's presidency  making her the longest-serving Attorney  General since 1829 Reno had been at the  Justice Department for just two years  when she noticed her hand shaking and  was diagnosed in 1995 with Parkinson's  disease under medication she continued  her work and became an inspiration for  others managing the disease